cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I hate to do this to you but
we're we're gonna do it uh I want to
start this segment by apologizing to all
of you for putting this image in your
head
but it is breaking news and I believe
this shows the depravity and the evil of
the people who are in opposition or I
should say our establishment uniparty
and what
from CNN former Trump aide Cassidy
Hutchinson claims Rudy Giuliani groped
her on day of attack on Capital wow such
a shocking story to come out a day
before her book release is that right
yes a day or two something I don't know
the exact timing but yep wow oh so she
accused Rudy Giuliani of groping her
that's and that that's coming out in her
book so congratulations PR Company hit
the nail on that with the hammer you
people are evil I I have a problem or
I've always had a problem with people
falsely caught using racism as an excuse
for everything and and my problem was
that racism is a useful term and it's a
real thing and it's something that
honestly I think we should frown upon
like you should not judge people based
on the color of their skin you shouldn't
prejudge people you should judge people
by the way they behave you know by their
actions towards you like that's that's
something that we should hope that we do
in our society
and the way that the left has used
racism as a tactic as opposed to a
description they've used it to say okay
this is this this is why you should hate
this person this is why you should
disregard what this person said and
they've made it so first of all people
have become somewhat numb to the term to
the word racism if you get called to
racist nowadays people are kind of like
are they really saying that I'm racist
are they just calling me a name because
they don't like me so that's a bad thing
because it's useful and second of all it
covers for actual racist so it gives
them a way to hide it gives them a way
to kind of you know stealth around and
if that's happening with other things
like sexual assault you don't want so
you don't want people in your Society to
say I don't believe her like that is
that's always been an argument against
false accusations and the more this is
used as a tactic the more real people
that were really sexually assaulted are
going to have problems convincing people
that they were hurt and this is horrible
this is gonna this is going to hurt real
women real live people that are gonna
actually have to deal with the fact that
they get sexually assaulted and then
more people are going to doubt what they
say and it's going to make it it's only
gonna make it harder this is all bad for
us all bad there's no winners so uh I
said Giuliani political adviser Ted
Goodman in a statement called
Hutchinson's claims a disgusting lie
quote it's fair to ask Cassidy
Hutchinson why she is just now coming
out with these allegations from two and
a half years ago as part of the
marketing campaign for her upcoming book
release this is a disgusting lie against
mayor Rudy Giuliani a man whose
distinguished career in public service
includes taking down the mafia cleaning
up New York City and comforting the
nation following September 11th
I'm not going to read you know whatever
she's claiming
but I think this one right here shows
they jump the shark I'm sorry dude when
this crackpot woman who's full of crap
comes out and accuses Rudy Giuliani and
it's funny that what's happening Rudy
Giuliani Russell Brand and Tim bout all
at the exact same time
shocking no one no one believes you
anymore no one believed you since that
mattress girl when those messages got
published showing that she was begging
the dude to hook up with her and then
later claimed that he abused her like
dude I'm just so sick of it these people
are evil and it's it's if if you can't
effectively like we we need to
effectively and and in very simple terms
just show these stories to regular
people
well first of all two and a half years
ago was the heart of the metoo movement
so it would have been a ripe time first
if this happened she should have come
out and been like look this guy's a
creep here's what happened and this is
exactly what happened think about the
inertia that would have gotten at the
time book wasn't done yet exactly
and what I I didn't realize who this
woman was until I you just pulled up her
picture what was her testimony on
January was she the one that said that
Trump tried to steal the the car and
drive it out like oh is that her I think
right what I mean she testified in front
of the January 6 committee uh did she I
just all she's a former Special
Assistant to president Donald Trump and
his Chief of Staff Mark Meadows yeah
yeah he intended to go to the Capitol at
the last minute I think she was the one
who said that he reached for the
steering wheel yeah there you go you
tried to tried to fight and it's it's
like the crazy thing is all it's all
probably false right you can't jump
between the the separate he was in the
was they say he was in the Beast or
whatever he was in he was in the limo I
believe it was right he lunged to the
front of his presidential limo and tried
to turn the wheel there's a there's a
partition has any people ever been in a
limousine before it makes no sense so
yeah she had like a crazy January 6th
that was a wild day for her I guess I
tried to do that at prom unfortunately
the partition was up yeah I mean look I
whatever this was this was actually a
big Scandal when she reported this
because a lot of people pointed out like
hey that uh in fact what was it like he
wasn't in the limo or something like
that or what was the story it's been a
while yeah I don't I don't even remember
I just started seeing her face that's
that's what it brought to mind and I
just remember it being uh utterly
ridiculous uh like I know again I
haven't looked into her accusations of
Rudy Giuliani but uh on first blush they
seem pretty ridiculous as well and yeah
I mean the question is like okay what do
like we're really in a tough spot
because it's not like you can easily
like punish people for making false
accusations without like really damaging
the ability for people to make actual
accusations because Suddenly It's like
oh if I make this accusation and I can't
prove it I'm gonna go to jail I'm just
not gonna make the accusation again so
they really they they sort of have us in
a position where like they they can make
these accusations even if they're
totally false there's no risk to them
because if we were to try to put
anything in place to prevent false
accusations then really the person that
you're hurting is people making actual
accusations so it's really just taking
advantage of uh of you know good human
nature in a way that only these evil
evil people are capable of doing I just
think it's hilarious that we've got
Russell Brand Tim Ballard and Giuliani
all at the same time like oh dude I'm
sorry man you guys need to coordinate
your campaigns better because it makes
it even less believable you couldn't
spend five minutes getting the phone
before launching these ridiculous smears
against these dudes
yeah and and again it just has nothing
to do with what the accusations are
about it's it's
just like they're in their investigating
Elon Musk for 900 different things
really they hate him because he wants to
open up uh Twitter X and have free
speech like that's the thing that they
actually want to stop him from doing
they can't just do that so they have to
try to come up with a hundred different
other ways of going at them and uh it's
it's blatant and obvious but uh
frustrating because you have to deal
with all these different attacks all of
a sudden
so it sounds like
the story is that he was talking to
everybody behind like backstage and then
he like put his arm somewhat around her
while holding the documents and kept
talking about the election
and that's that's that's the story and
she goes on to say like you know his
fingers are trailing and I'm just it's
just it's not like cold fingers dude I'm
not it's not real like this is this is
like weird weird psychotic I think the
issue is
I gotta be honest
um women love True Crime
you know and we've talked about this
before the Donald Trump Saga is the
premier true crime podcast
that's why they have Mueller she wrote
or whatever is that show still is they
still doing that podcast unfortunately
yeah how Mueller ended years ago when
did Mueller in 2019
yeah
four years ago and they're still they're
still doing that let's uh let me look
that up and gold nothing burger and and
that and that by the way that podcast
too
if we're talking about the same one the
person who runs it came out everything
came out as being false and completely
made up like her history everything that
she claims to be Etc
Mueller she wrote jeez
how did it it's just it really it really
guys it's demoralizing that there are
people who vote for for these people I
can understand if you're like I won't
vote for Mitch McConnell I'm like I
agree I can understand if you're like
the rank and file Republicans are our
awful uniparties you know speed bumps
for Democrats and I'm like yeah you know
and then if you go and you say like
you're gonna vote for a Democrat I'm
just like how does how do you how does
that happen you know what I mean uh you
know most people are not uh paying
attention to this Source I think you and
I were talking about this uh before the
show you know they just see the
headlines and the mainstream media's
primary role in America today is to tell
the truth they have to tell the truth
they have to stick to the facts but they
leave you believing a lie so and I mean
it's with big things too I mean recently
the thing that was revealed was there
was a big missile attack that they
blamed on Russia that killed civilians
and of course that's the headline that
gets him playing in people's heads
Russia evil Russia evil and then it came
out it was the Ukrainian uh missile but
it comes out quietly several months
later nobody really cares and when you
do that enough and you have enough
stories coming out like that you know
they're building layer upon layer upon
layer of lie so you know I've had
conversations with people talking about
January 6th where they go you know yeah
Trump you know called for violence
because this is what he does remember it
during the campaign you know his people
were violent during the 2016 campaign
it's like okay so in order to debunk the
LIE of 2021 I gotta go all the way back
to 2016 and all of the lies in between
there and they're not going to believe
any of it either because they're already
invested in the narrative that Donald
Trump is bad yeah the the seed is
sprouted so I posted this on my Twitter
today and you gotta look this story up
there's this guy and he's digging a hole
in the beach right and he goes look at
what happened with the hole that was dug
in the beach and it's just him on Tick
Tock and then it cuts to a story in the
news and they're like it looks like a
meteor hit the beach and we have a
scientist here and they're talking about
this guy's hole that's fake oh that was
oh my God I got it I bought the whole
thing yeah so this is something we
talked I talked with uh Alex Stein about
I was like bro this is your new play
find news stories and then film yourself
doing the thing in the story and then
just edit it before the news story
because people believe it well and the
reason I believed that it was actually
true was because I believed that they
would do something like that so they
would reverse but that's the thing like
everybody wanted to believe that story
and if you actually look at the videos
they're not even the same beach one has
houses in the back left of the video and
and the ocean to the right the video
video from the news report has an island
to the right and and shrubberries to the
left and I'm just like that like the
first time I saw that video I was just
like these are not the same place but
then everybody just keeps retweeting it
because they want it to be real well
same point same exact point maybe maybe
there is like a camera angle thing where
you couldn't see the island and it was
it's true fine whatever but I tell you
you see a news story where they're like
we found a hole in the beach then you go
to the beach dig a hole put your video
in front and say haha it was us and
people believe it yeah that actually is
pretty smart either way it got me yeah
this is another thing I was talking
about with um we used to do like viral
marketing pitches one of them was
uh was basically this one of the ideas
is
you can walk around New York City until
you see an ambulance or just like the
moment you see an ambulance doing
something anywhere you film it and then
you come back the next day just before
the same time so the sunlight is is the
same and then film whatever ridiculous
thing you want to be the story so then
the ambulance makes it look believable
and real because if you had uh my joke
was like you have a a Cookie Monster
beating the crap out of a guy dressed
like a giant cookie because it's an
absurd thing and then people are going
to be like that's fake that's not real
and then also it shows the ambulance
there and you're going dude wow and I'm
like whoa now they believe it's real so
that's the viral marketing campaign
strategy you see with videos like this
well when people are doing that quite a
bit the latest one was the woman tearing
down the rainbow flag in the uh
classroom and it just is I mean to me
it's obviously fake from the outset it's
like you've got like 30 year old people
pretending to be high school kids or you
know and I think maybe it's the same
company or a different one that does uh
the you know viral encounters on a plane
and it's like that is not but the full
video shows a scenario and then the
people say thanks for watching our video
right what do you think about this
scenario that we proposed today leave a
comment below and it's like
their their Clips are are obviously fake
when they present them but then other
people take them snip them out of
context and then try and pass them off
and people buy and people believe it hey
you gotta it it really frustrates me
there's the first one I saw was it's the
girl in the classroom wearing a bikini
and the teacher's like you can't wear
that in my class and I'm like these are
adults I just ignore it it's it look if
people are wondering why it is that I
rarely post uh videos that are wrong I
just for whatever reason ignore very
obviously fake posts or I'll call them
out when the Covington kids things
happen my my first thought was I get all
these people hitting me up being like
you got to look at what these kids did
and I'm like what are they doing like
here's the video and I look at it I'm
like I don't understand and they're like
look what the kid's doing I'm like
what's he doing like he got in the face
of that Native American guy and I was
like it's just a video of two people
standing next to each other bro what
you're talking about so when I watch the
full video other way around but people
want things to be true yeah so they just
believe it so when these videos come out
where you've got these actors staging a
high school room and there's a carpet
that's the first thing I notice I'm like
there's no carpet in high school
classroom is people believe in this
stuff and then it turns out they're just
comedians they're actors putting on fake
bits
it's like everybody wants to believe
that a mother tore down a pride flag in
a classroom and I'm like they're in an
office building look at the drop ceiling
yeah it makes no sense there's a drop
ceiling and a carpet that's not a high
school
people want to believe it but the desire
to believe is also emblematic of a lot
of these stories and what we were just
talking about is that when one story
comes out and it's thought of as the
truth for even five minutes or just one
news cycle that's it it's a there's
never kind of like a retroactive
re-examination of the story and that's
ultimately you know everything related
to Trump I I think people really do not
understand what AI is going to do in
2024. yep I think you're entirely
correct let me let me give you a
scenario
do you remember uh
let's say uh do you remember everything
we talked about earlier we're talking
about restaurants Chef gruel
uh about 95 of it yeah and so if I
played a recording back for you that
sounded about right you'd be like yeah
that sounds like I can't remember
exactly what we said but that sounds
like what you said yeah and then what if
I change one word
you'd be like so I'll give you a
scenario Donald Trump gets on the phone
in 2024 and he says it's let's let's say
it's September
and he says
to you know Giuliani or whoever look we
gotta get out the vote we gotta get
people to go knock on doors we need 50
000 votes it's the only way we're gonna
win this one we lost it last time
he doesn't remember exactly what he said
audio gets dropped where Trump goes we
need to fake the vote we need 50 000
votes because we lost by that last time
get it done and they're like whoa and
change one thing get out to fake what
happens then is you'll end up with Trump
in court
I'm using this as a hypothetical
scenario just it could be anybody and
they'll say did you speak with Giuliani
your legal advisor
on or around September 5th in the
afternoon uh I don't recall I might have
okay well I have the call logs here this
is this this is your your these are your
call logs yes okay I believe so okay
yeah the phone company confirms I'm
gonna play for you some recordings that
we've gotten that were given to us and
then the recording will say Donald Trump
being like hey Rudy it's really good to
hear from you we've got big big plans
we're working on great stuff and then
anything like is this you know it's like
sounds like me yes and do you remember
having this conversation yes I do
remember this conversation show clip one
sounds like you do remember it yes show
clip two sounds like you do remember it
yes sound play clip three sounds like
you yes you're talking about elections
and the work you're doing yes of course
and then play fake clip this is where in
the conversation that you've already
agreed did happen that you were part of
and these things were all true in this
clip you tell Giuliani to fabricate
votes no that's not true that's not real
but you've already confirmed everything
else
AI can do this right now and what people
don't understand is you don't remember
everything you said on every
conversation and you don't even know
when you're being recorded they're
they're look
there there will be instances where
somebody is like Trump's been recorded
and they've released these audio tapes
and Trump's response is going to be in
defense of what he said not realizing he
never said it
it's a good point it's a good point and
it's a scary Prospect so what's what's
what's the defense mechanism I mean
there's not ahead of that or is it
there's no defense yeah there if audio
comes out that sounds somewhat
reasonable like something Trump may have
said Trump's response is not going to be
that's a deep fake audio never said that
because that's not believable
he'll say well you know I said that
because we are work we like we didn't
mean to to fake it we were uh because
the Natural Instinct people have when
they hear a recording of themselves is
to try and explain away or Justify why
they said the things they said
yeah it is weird we've um we actually
did a thing where it was a guy at
Infowars took my voice and has me
reading like the Declaration of
Independence and it's freaky hearing
your own voice say things that you've
never said it's like a it's not a very
uh comfortable position to be in I
wonder how big of a problem that's going
to be though because I mean we've had
Photoshop forever and and you know ai's
made it extremely easy to make anybody
say anything uh but that's not
necessarily a new technology I wonder
how effective that's going to be or if
that's the ubiquity the fact that anyone
can create an audio recording of any
politician that sounds indistinguishable
for the real from the real thing there's
going to be uh we've already seen it
happen with James O'Keefe they say this
a video went viral claiming to be James
O'Keefe alleging something like we've
uncovered this evidence and it was a
totally fabricated video it was
imperfect because these AIS are not that
good yet but some of them are good
enough and if if you put enough work
into it you can name feel the speech so
for instance 11 Labs is the website
where you can take 30 seconds of anyone
talking
upload it and that's it now you can
write anything you want and you'll get
anyone anyone to say it just insert
personality and they'll say what you
want them to say however the inflection
can be off timing can be off you have to
use clever tricks like using ellipses
commas record one sentence erase it
record another sentence sometimes the
sentences aren't ended definitively they
end with an upward inflection and then
you're like okay that's that's weird
but if someone actually spent a week
using this program and generating The
Voice you would not be able to tell the
difference I think the scarier Prospect
though is that even if it is proven
false as long as it's really good and
it's made its way across the entire
social media landscape it's imprinted in
at least 60 percent of Americans Minds
right and then nobody ever covers the
story when it comes out as false that's
the scary thing right so it's really
just adding authenticity to existing
lies
here let's try this I just typed it out
let's see what happens
give it a second this is robot Jordan
Peterson all hail the lobster King
so talk in my language and I want to
stress too this is we don't have this
pull-up Carter so uh I wanna I wanna
stress too that uh this recording I have
of Jordan Peterson's voice I did not do
anything like I did not work on this at
all I literally found like a podcast and
just snipped at 30 seconds and put it in
if you actually found clean clear audio
from Jordan himself and then uploaded it
it would sound way better
so what's the solution just record
yourself at all times just constantly
have that makes it worse that makes it
worse no I mean like you record yourself
yeah go back and go here's what I
actually said it makes it worse because
you're not going to be able to dig
through 5 000 hours of of audio
recordings to figure out what you
actually said and when it was said
someone so I mean how many how many uh
uh we what do I do we got an hour and a
half Tim uh Temple Daily Show followed
by three hours of Tim cast IRL
four hours four and a half hours every
day of me and various people talking if
someone pulled up a transcript I'd be
like I don't know what you're talking
about yeah every day for three years nah
we try to collect footage when we're in
the studio we're just in in uh doing
drums a couple months back and we you
know just started recording when we were
there and left it running until it
filled up basically and you you do run
into a problem where you've got so much
material you don't know where to look
for stuff unless you actually start
tagging stuff and saying okay Mark this
Mark this Mark this that was funny or
something and it just becomes
overwhelming so there's no way you're
going to be able to just like record the
things that you say and say yes I did
say this no I didn't say that there's
it's just there's it's just too much
material too much content yeah in
skateboarding when you're filming a
trick after the trick has landed you
what they used to do because it was mini
DV tapes is they would put their hand
over and they would wave their hand then
when you speed through the video to try
and find out where the trick is you as
soon as you see the hand wave in front
of the camera you need to stop
it still kind of is that way because
you're going to have 70 video files in
your camera and you're gonna be like
which one was the was the was the Lander
and so you could either tag it in the
camera or you can wave your hand and
then you look and what you see all these
clips and then one with a thumbnail of a
hand in front of it but there's no way
you're going back through 300 Clips
throughout the day seven hours of
recorded content for the past couple
days to try and figure out where someone
landed a trick it's just never gonna
happen if I'm a hostile country I'm
going to use this to my advantage
right oh I mean people don't even think
about the the war elements that's what
I'm saying we're talking just like
political foes but now you know I'm
North Korea China any of these countries
that we think are ultimately coming
after us and they are I'm I'm gonna just
completely manipulate everybody I feel
like uh the whole Russia probe and and
stuff that the Clinton campaign did uh
to attack Donald Trump was already like
a laying the groundworker or yeah
demonstrating I'm not I'm I'm not so
sure how much a foreign government is
going to have a preference from one
president to another I mean I I assume
just to create chaos right yeah that
does that I mean that makes sense uh but
I do think that it's it's more of a
honey trap for or honey pot for a
candidate to do something as to an
opposing candidate then then for a a
foreign country
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time